[Applause]
[Music]
we've hosted many celebrations since the
launch of this most relevant of games
we look far and wide to bring you the
most up-to-date and interesting topics
but then there is one subject that we
somehow missed
welcome home my tuber friends every home
is different and love is central to
every one of them
it's a theme that is sure to appear in
our room events i look forward to
virtually visit your dwellings
[Music]
what's up gaming minds month it's one
month
relax here we are in my beautiful home
welcome to my home
we have uh two furnaces that's right
bet you didn't know you can add two of
them you're dumb dumb
we got a lot of stuff that needs to be
done we just started this i'm gonna
start smelting iron
yeah aren't you glad you clicked on this
video so you can watch me some other
pirates
yeah with my two furnaces
yeah i need food
i'm hungry let me go out and kill
something really quick be right back
guys
wow if i die i die i pew die die
that time i die three times actually
then the hell what are you doing here
no oh god me we got me oh my god there's
so many ravines in this
woo hey does that make you nervous
playing on hardcore what is gonna
funny oh my god there's a bunny mine
don't worry bunnies
don't worry i'm not gonna hurt you i'm
not gonna hurt you
i'm not gonna hurt anyone oh run little
buddy run
run
oh you thought you could make it out
alive didn't you
be i'm faster i'm stronger i'm bigger
i'm better i'm sexy
all right you're sick you're sexier
you're sexy i'm sorry i'm sorry stop
moving i'm joking
oh now you're pissing me off dude oh
it's not a baby bunny
they must double die then oh my god
you're
so tiny and annoying i i didn't have to
do that there was no reason for that
but i did it and now i feel good anyway
back to home
it's getting dark look at my beautiful
house it's so gorgeous
dude can you die just
i need a bow i need to organize some way
to get food i need to get the cows or
something i don't know
okay how's my iron doing nice cool so
now we can make
a bucket which i know in my brain how to
do
it's in here just like i know how to say
negligible
[ __ ] negligible
thank you thank you we're also going to
make a shield
which i also know how to make in my
brain
i just choose not to okay and then
we're gonna go down and we're gonna get
some more obsidian am i too low level to
go in the nether that's what a coward
would say
if they play hardcore luckily i'm a man
i'm not afraid of anything except
hitting my head in the staircase
all right i'm prepared for whatever
danger lies ahead
i ain't afraid of no one
all right here we go nice i'm not gonna
die
oh my god i'm not gonna die it's not
happening
oh god every sound scares me
i'm not afraid this is not making me
anxious
at all oh i got it nice yeah
i get some coal yeah
yeah i'll dig straight down i don't even
give a [ __ ]
that's how i roll
i'm never doing that again i'm sorry i'm
sorry
give me that straight down
[Laughter]
that's why you dig straight down you
cowards
[ __ ] weaklings this is how you play
minecraft hardcore baby
old balls mode all balls no skill
hell yeah oh
[ __ ] stop it stop
it we're fine we're absolutely fine
i wasn't scared for a second yeah
damn it feels good to be so hard that
sounds weird when i say it but i meant
like as
goddamn now i can make a
enchantment table this is awesome guys
we're off for a great start
i got a great feeling about this
hardcore mic we're going to beat the
underground
if i can make it up the staircase jesus
christ why did i build it in a mountain
there we go ah it's still night how do i
make enchantment table
wait what i need a book i don't have a
book
who has books what even is a book huh
all right well i'm expanding the house a
little bit
i swear minecraft is scarier than any
game
on the planet
i can't do this guy so take it back i'm
not hard i'm soft i'm soft as hell man
no no no no we're not doing that we're
not doing that
oh no
ugh stop
go away
oh my gosh i need i'm so lowly
i oh no need
no no i'm so lonely and afraid and
stinky
i make windows hey how are you doing uh
you're gonna burn you know that you're
gonna burn
i ain't afraid if i screamed it was a
defense
mechanism of superiority
what had it boots
diamond boots baby hell yeah hey guys
you can have my wooden sword my precious
all right doing good i'm alive as long
as i'm alive i think i'm doing amazing
okay this is nice this is nice
can i cook the stairs no what's the
point
okay we need to seriously do something
about our food situation this is not
gonna work
i need a book and i need me two things i
would like in real life as well
how's this going grow
grow see it works gro
look at that amazing we have uh wheat
meat meat wheat so let's build a little
house for the couch
usually people put a little uh a
barnyard or something where they can go
outdoors and have fun
we're not doing that not my house okay
they live in a dungeon
my cows live in a hole in a dungeon they
will get no sunlight they will go at no
nutrition i want them as
as tormented as possible because that
that way they taste better
double security they're never gonna
escape from this hell hole
this will be the fort knox of cow
can we oh god
where are they there you are there you
are
come with me yeah hey guys
hey guys hey come
follow me guys what's that
no i'm not gonna force you into a hole
and make you reproduce
and kill your children and eat them in
front of you no that's not happening
hey hey trust me i'm a nice guy
i'm pewdiepie you can rely on me
oh my god there's death traps everywhere
in this game are you serious
do not push me remind me to cover that
up all right
seriously i'm not dying crawling through
the holes
that is not happening almost there hey
hey hey hey
follow yeah stinky dumbass couch
come here yeah this is your new home
yeah oh my god just squeeze in
one at a time please
no oh you died then you died then see
how's dead
how's dead happy death yeah
yeah that's right you've all been
bamboozled now frick
frick now i command you yeah
make a baby your baby belongs to me
baby i'm corpse cool
we got meat now check right epic
let me cook them your friend gonna taste
so good
i can't believe i don't have any friends
in this game where's
i don't get it
absolutely
it doesn't make any sense
oh man we got some stone
nice now we can make fancy stairs
which i will have thank you how should
it go like here
yeah that's nice i'm def i need a stare
i need to stare real bad
real bad you ever start something and
start questioning what the hell am i
doing
that's everything i do in life now you
know how i feel
oh that's nice that's safe
i don't understand you guys explain it
to me
i don't understand how you can die in
minecraft hardcore mode
like just don't die
so stupid just don't die bro how hard is
it
i've done it my entire life all right
there we go
no get out of my house
no not like this not like this please
please please
please what hell that's illegal
we're fine oh wait i need a book yeah
damn it all right i'm gonna head out
really quick
don't kill me guys uh
no i'm not gonna head out i'm not gonna
have it i'm not heading i'm not i'm not
i'm not doing it i'm not doing it i'm
not doing it
i have a shield though i do have a
shield i have a shield i'm i'll be fine
trust me i'll be fine trust me hey guys
i'm playing in hardcore mode
go easy on me all right i just need that
all right i need a battle plan
so i cue the epic music something cooler
yeah that's it that's it yeah
submission impossible skipper
there they are hardcore more baby that
means playing hardcore not like a child
give me that yeah give me that
yeah give me give me give me hey nice
boots my dude
how many books can i make out of this
isn't this how you make books
oh god side cue the music
everything is terrifying everything shut
up
shut up
wait what they're not growing up oh i
should really start placing some torches
around my base right
i could really use your bones give me
your bone your bones
your bones what was that sound
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm so scared leave me alone leave me
alone
[Laughter]
oh god forgive me
what oh book book book book book we got
a book
we got a book watch this book
book that's a book
okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah what why what do you want from
me
oh god yes i got yes yes
i knew i i knew i could make boots
trust me guys i know what i'm doing all
right
give me something good efficiency too
that's the best enchantment nice oh i
forgot to place mine
guys i could really i could really uh
what was that no nope nope nope
nope all right i need some lava all
right give me that
nice damn i'm fast
how am i supposed to get out of here
he's camping bro please
i got a family i got i got a fan bro
please two children please you're
they're like fathers to me both of them
dead you're so dead you dumbass you fell
for the old
i am father trick dumbass
so dumb bullish my mind how stupid
people are
all right let's lift this up i don't
want to die
[Laughter]
i can't do this my nerves man
i can't i don't know hardcore
it's too much for me i can't do it
i miss man
oh it's daytime thank god all right i'm
gonna make a lava pit
it might seem foolish but i i need to
throw away stuff in it
right oh oh okay nice we have the bone
meat now as well yeah
bird hope you suffer
give me the wheat dude
yeah we're expanding nice
all right frick do it now
more make more cow i'm hungry
i could really use killing some cheap
actually i need the wool
the sheep house will be uh slightly
bigger
because sheep are better than cows
it's only fair really bro i need to make
a bed i'm sorry
all right it's it's
i i will i need sleep all right dude
this island
sucks why am i so lonely
dude oh great another hole of death nice
efficiently
patched up
come here please please i'm so lonely
baby come here oh my god i'm so glad i
missed you man
where were you come on home buddy we'll
go home man
dude you went far away from home when
you're far away from home
[Music]
sorry i'm 30 years old i keep forgetting
and you only have your
that's right your beatboxing b i get it
now it's cool
it's cool come in come in welcome
welcome my friend this is my house
i need to fix that i'm working on it
there we go
you live here now you understand me
you will never leave me right i love you
understand me don't fly in the lava okay
that's the only rule of this place
there you go there you go have fun
hey hey don't get freaky now
hey hey no no no
bad beeps bad
hey hey stop nudging me you're annoying
you're annoying me you're annoying me
you're annoying me stop it why can't i
make bed three wool
does it have to be the same color i
shouldn't have killed the sheep should i
all right that hey don't fly in the
chest
you're no deep don't follow me all right
i need to get some obsidian i'll be
right back see the good thing about
playing on hardcore is that i can is i
can wear anything all right i don't have
to worry about it
[Music]
you scare me so much and i hate you so
much for it
oh shoot i'm getting sidetracked again i
came here for obsidian
where did you come from where did you go
cut
my bow okay i can make linton still nice
you didn't fly in the lava you're a good
[Music]
you're the shittiest character of all
time
no one likes you i read the comments
they hate you
don't worry i love you though don't
worry oh
ooh protection one that's the best one
in the game
you guys probably don't know that
because you're not veterans like i am
okay so now we can build a nether portal
right what's that
i should wait until it gets right shut
up i'm playing on hardcore i know what
i'm doing
okay maybe i will you're right maybe i
will only i had a bed
okay stay there feeding time
feeding time prick
frick boom boom boom
boom i'm not singing in the song because
so copyright
oh god damn it okay
[Music]
yeah okay all right all right
all right i'm making a better sword
god damn it side do something
[Music]
hey fight the man
god damn it help me
[ __ ] it's getting worse
this suck i can't okay
wait i can think away a hiccup
yeah i got it
[Music]
god damn it all right i got hiccups one
of you have to die
sorry i don't make the rules god i hate
hiccups so no
annoying at least you don't escape
a lot of people don't know this but you
can actually make three furnaces
bet you didn't know about that minecraft
better
all right guys we have the sword
we have the shield we have the full
expected diamond boots with the best
protection
it's time for me to enter on hardcore
mode
[Music]
in the next episode smudge like
subscribe
for more videos and check out graph
i'm perfect
yes huge thank you to everyone for
supporting the arcade indiegogo campaign
it was a huge success to say the least
look at this thing
it's beautiful now as a popular demand
this thing now works with pc games top
pc games
i'm talking call of duty doom gotta try
this baby on doom
pub g valorent you name me
okay we don't have every game but a ton
of games so the blaster now works with
geforce now which is very cool
it also works on pc it has a ton of
library of android games
it's just a new way to play we're
bringing it to you so
the product is now available at
arcade.games
the website itself is very cool check it
out
honestly but you also get ten dollars
off if you enter the code
pewdiepie to get one of these bad boys
so yeah link is in the description
check it out